[Music]
all right
hey what's up mkbhd here so what if i
told you
this new 2020 smartphone
is just 129 dollars sometimes
for some people maybe also it kind of
does look like an among us character
[Music]
[Applause]
but this new poco m3 is popping up on a
lot of radars right now it's a really
interesting phone from a really
interesting company so this
poco company just went independent uh
from the brand xiaomi it was originally
the xiaomi pocophone
now poco's independent by themselves but
i wouldn't put as much
stock in this new independence as they
probably want us to
i feel like they're about as independent
as the mustang
is from ford you know there's no
forward logos on any mustangs but we all
know that they're getting some of the
expertise
and manufacturing and financial support
from that
bigger company still so poco by
themselves is not a small company
but they definitely want to look like
and act like one but that being said
this poco m3 is insane value
as a full-fledged smartphone i've talked
about this in the past how budget phones
are getting better around 400 bucks
300 bucks even 200 bucks but to get
something like this
and not even crack 150 bucks shipped
landed arrived at your door in certain
regions anyway
is incredibly impressive the design if
you start there is actually
quite nice i would say we already know
every premium phone tries to go shiny
glass or at least look like glass but
this is more of a
faux leather made of plastic and i
always say if you're gonna go plastic
embrace the plastic don't pull a samsung
for example
and look me dead in the eyes and call it
glastic but no plastic can be good
lean into it this i already know will
never show fingerprints the same way
glass does
it's less likely to shatter you can do
whatever you want with color
it's nice plastic is fine on cheap
phones then there is
of course that cutout at the top with
the bold poco branding on it that kind
of looks like it glows sometimes even
though it's not
they're really leaning into this it
looks kind of like that cyberpunk
oneplus phone window now
and there's a triple camera system up
here 48 megapixel main sensor
2 megapixel macro and 2 megapixel
depth sensor so i feel like you already
know
where i'm going with this one the best
budget
smartphone cameras are single camera
systems
pixel 4a iphone se maybe two cameras at
best if they toss an ultrawide in there
but this doesn't have an ultra wide yet
adds two more
2 megapixel sensors for macro and depth
not what i would have done i will say
the poco's main camera is acceptable
in pretty much average and normal
shooting conditions
it does of course struggle in low light
or in difficult shooting conditions but
we just came off the heels of the blind
smartphone camera test where we realized
that it's really a matter of taste in a
lot of these cases and what i can say is
this phone despite its poor dynamic
range can spit out some pretty decent
looking photos
the macro camera maybe you could argue
is useful because it has
a much shorter minimum focus distance
than the main camera
but you can't convince me this 2
megapixel depth sensor
is useful sorry i still would have much
preferred over both of these
to scene and ultrawide then around the
front there's a very average
1080p 6.53 inch display with a teardrop
notch at the top
perfectly acceptable bezels you know a
little bit of chin
and sure there's not great viewing
angles or maximum brightness
but again it is totally fine for this
price point we're talking about here
and then the best part easily the best
part the best spec of them all
this phone has a 6 000
milliamp hour battery 6 000 milliamp
hours
and it's not even that thick or massive
the only other phone i've tested with a
battery that's actually this big
is the rog phone 3 and look at the size
of that phone so this is a gigantic
battery pack in here
that should last anybody all day and
then some honestly i wouldn't be
surprised if some people saw
two days of use at 60hz here on the
regular plus there is 18 watt fast
charging
this phone has a headphone jack up here
too you love to see it it also has
a large front-facing earpiece speaker
and it has a fingerprint reader
in the power button another great combo
for a budget phone right now in my
opinion
and it comes with a clear case and a
screen protector in case you want to
protect
that precious plastic and they even
built in reverse
wired charging so there's no wireless
charging but you can
top up and use this phone's huge battery
as a battery bank so you can charge
other things like your headphones
or even another phone if you're into
that the one thing i'd tell you to be
aware of though
this phone is not fast
so if you're coming from a higher speed
higher performance phone or if you just
have a need for high speed or
performance
you're not going to find it here this
phone's rocking a snapdragon 662
and four gigs of ram and with that spec
i found myself
waiting for everything waiting for the
camera to open
waiting to snap the picture waiting for
all the apps really to open
waiting for apps to close waiting for
multitasking
waiting for animations to finish it's
just a slow phone and it's impossible
not to notice that
now i know you can't be overly picky
about performance for less than 200
bucks but
i kind of worry on a phone like this
just about how it will age over time
because of course it's not getting
faster but overall if i'm just
evaluating this
what you get for the money especially
with the hardware package this
is a really complete impressive phone
for 129
bucks so seems like that's it that's
what you should
print as the headline right amazing
129 dollar phone
well let's talk about that i've wanted
to talk about this concept for a while
there's a lot of
different versions of ways to talk about
price
in phones especially in this ultra low
budget category
never really put them all in one place
so this particular phone
has made a lot of headlines as a 129
phone which is impressive like in this
race to the bottom where we're trying to
make the best like ultra low budget
thing you possibly can and undercut
everyone
that is a nice headline to grab but that
129
price as you may have heard is what's
called their
early bird pricing which means that for
a limited time or a limited volume
you can get the base version of this at
the the lower price and there's
lower early bird prices then once that
volume is up once that time is up the
price
goes back up to the regular prices
permanently forever
but all those articles and all those
headlines about the 129 dollar phone
stay up so okay you might be thinking
well how long does this early bird thing
last couple months couple weeks a couple
days
well they'll never say they don't want
you to know but there's plenty of
science and studies behind
this whole early bird pricing model the
idea is
it's very brief they want you to not
think too hard and they just want you to
buy fast
and then as soon as that's all over
it'll just rise back up to the normal
price
and that's how they get you the early
bird version tends to be sold out
very very quickly but with this phone
returning to its normal price
shortly after and all those headlines
remain so now if you get this phone if
you're
if you're a youtuber or you're writing
an article
do you write as your headline that this
is
technically a 129 phone even though most
people reading the article or watching
the video
will not be able to get it at that price
tough to say but then the other version
of this uh this little price trick that
they like to play
is basically the concept of a base
version
that is cheapest and has a number that's
really appealing
but that you probably shouldn't buy
probably because there's some obvious
upgrades
kind of the same thing again like you
see in cars where they'll all say
starting at 199.99 which is great but
that version
doesn't have air conditioners or radio
or something like that you obviously
don't get many people paying that price
for the car
there's a higher end version most people
should get
you see that with with storage on the
iphone you see that with phones
like this all the time i remember not
that long ago the first pocophone came
out
and they made a lot of headlines as a
300 phone
but they sent reviewers including myself
they sent almost everyone the 400 carbon
fiber back version of the phone that had
double the storage and more ram so we're
all reviewing
this version of this amazing new 300
phone and it's weird we're like trying
to give it the benefit of the doubt that
it's probably
about the same experience but then again
you have to assume it's probably not the
same experience if they made the choice
to send us all
the more expensive version so with this
poco m3 it's actually not all that bad
honestly at 129 or 149 bucks
this phone is still a hell of a deal and
it's an achievement that phones are
getting this good at this price like i
said you got to know what you're getting
into here
this phone obviously runs poco's my ui
over android 10 and it doesn't have 5g
doesn't have wireless charging or water
resistance you're of course limiting
yourself in some ways
as far as future proofing but again
anytime i see a full-fledged smartphone
get this low in price
i gotta hand it to them i gotta applaud
that level of accessibility so just a
word to those who keep
loving to say oh smartphones have gotten
so boring now
they're all the same thing now that is
one of the benefits
of the commoditization of the smartphone
is now you can
mass produce something pretty decent
at an amazingly low price um and then
leave the
innovation and crazy fun stuff to the
high end with all the flipping and
twisting and folding and rolling but
yeah my take on the poco m3 is it is a
net positive
it's good to see this kind of stuff
exist and uh let me know what you think
could you rock a phone daily
that is this cheap and also for my
enthusiasts out there
what are your feelings on what feels
like poco like filling in the shoes that
oneplus
is leaving let me know if you have if
you have thoughts on that it might be
worth an entire separate video
anyway that's it for now thanks for
watching
shout out to honey for sponsoring this
video so you guys have heard about honey
by now right
but if you somehow haven't you
definitely should if you do any sort of
online shopping
which is kind of what we're all doing
now so honey is a free browser extension
that finds promo codes across the
internet and automatically tests them
for you
at checkout so you can get honey on your
computer for free
in two easy clicks just like any browser
extension then next time you're checking
out at one of its over 30 000 supported
sites
honey pops up and all you have to do is
click apply coupons
wait a few seconds and honey searches
for coupons for that site and if it
finds a working code you literally just
watch the price drop so in this holiday
season i've been saving money
on gifts for the fam yes i am the guy
that gives
tech gifts and yes mom i did save 30
bucks on your gift
but i can't tell you what it is yet but
if you're online shopping too
you should have honey it's free it works
with whatever browser you use
and like i said it's a free quick easy
two clicks to install
if you want to grab it you can go to
joinhoney.com mkbhd
to make sure they know i sent you again
link below
thanks again to honey for sponsoring
this video